now a report out today shows that hm
inspectorate of probation has serious
concerns about the effectiveness of
probation work with released prisoners
among the problems recall rates are high
with three in ten prisoners being
returned to custody it's highlighted
this morning by the news that Gary
Glitter has been recalled to prison for
a license breach just weeks after he was
freed while here with me now is the
chief executive of the criminal justice
charity unlock Angela Kent Angela thanks
so much for coming in and I suppose you
could say that that perhaps the system
has worked if Gary Glitter has been
recalled does it well there are a number
of sides to the system and the report
really highlighted some of the flaws in
it so
um it actually showed that the majority
of people are not being recalled
necessarily because they are reoffending
but because they have other factors in
there so uh four out of ten only four
out of 10 people were leaving prison and
going into settled accommodation and
only eight percent of people who will
work ready leaving prison were going
into work and those are things that
we've known for a really long time make
a big difference to people when they are
leaving prison so essentially that
they're coming out of prison and they're
slightly being cast adrift not being put
somewhere that's suitable or feels like
home and even though lots of them have
developed skills in inside prison those
aren't being put to use absolutely
absolutely it's a huge issue and and we
know employment is one of the the
biggest factors in people
um staying out of prison living positive
lives being able to move on themselves
so at unlock we have a helpline other
people can phone anyone with a criminal
record and by far the majority of of
contacts that we have with people and
that was 9 000 last year are about
employment and the complexities of doing
that a recent report by the charity
working chance also found
that 30 of employers would not employ
anyone with an unspent record and that
is everybody leaving prison at the
moment there are some employees that are
different though I mean I know timson's
for example you know that they've
they've made great strides haven't they
helping people I mean it's just an extra
thing I mean it's hard enough to find a
job for a lot of people these days but
how hard is it to get back on your feet
when when you you've come out of prison
and you've decided to turn your life
around it's incredibly complicated
because people who are in prison have
often got a myriad of of things that
they need to deal with so we've talked
about housing there's employment but
often Health as well so you may have
been getting support around drug alcohol
abuse when in prison you're released if
there's no continuity there then that's
problematic people often have mental
health conditions as well and we know
that neurodiversity is an issue for many
many people in prison so that if the
support is not there then they're not
able to take those next steps in itself
how a criminal record causes great
amount of stigma prejudice and
discrimination so people often have to
live with that for life
is there a sense too that a lot of
people especially if you're talking
about people who are neurodiverse
actually find it easier to be
institutionalized that actually the
routine of prison and and somebody else
making decisions
helps them and actually that they almost
when they come outside just find it easy
just to go back in
really so you know everybody was a
neurodiverse condition
um is different
um and they're all there's a whole
spectrum of them I have ADHD myself so
um the idea of being told what to do all
the time is is not something that I
would Relish in any shape or form and
often they are not necessarily getting
the support that they need anyway
um why do you think people still
continue to see former offenders in the
wrong light you know it is hard isn't it
yes I think especially if you perhaps
have a small company and and you only
have you know a few people there that
you could understand why people might
think I don't want to put myself at risk
I don't want to put my staff at risk
sure
um I think there is a a thing around the
language that's used around offending
around convictions
um we hear things on the news from
politicians and it causes stigma for
people but it also feeds into this idea
that anybody who has done anything wrong
ever anyone with a criminal record is
intrinsically bad and has no chance of
Rehabilitation and if we're going to
take Rehabilitation seriously which we
should be because it's for the benefit
of everybody we need to start seeing
people as human beings who can change we
can rehabilitate Angela Cairns from
unlock thanks very much